das ist vorbei ein bisschen wehmütig
räumt christine ständer mit ihren
freunden auf wie viele hier in
montgomery county in pennsylvania hatten
sie für ihre kandidaten in ihrem
vorgarten geworben
seit zwei jahren ist die juristin
amerikanische staatsbürgerin
es ist ihre erste wahl zugleich eine
jahrhundert war für ihre neue heimat wie
fühlt sie sich heute mir jetzt als
gruppe können jetzt immer mehr oder
weniger gar nichts machen wir warten
jetzt wie die wahl ausgeht und und
schauen sowie die sache im supreme court
entschieden wird und dann muss wenn man
die wahl verloren hat muss man sich
geschlagen geben aber trotzdem trotzdem
noch mit seinem nachbarn sprechen und
mit freunden und familie
bis zuletzt hatte sie gekämpft mit ihrer
gruppe individuell hoch die sie vor vier
jahren mit freunden gegründet hatte und
werben sie für die demokraten
doch der riss der durch amerika geht
geht auch mitten durch montgomery county
im speckgürtel von philadelphia hat auch
donald trump viele anhänger besonders
frauen schon einen tag vor der wahl
feiern sie den politischen tod von joe
biden
mike domenico hat aus dem wahlkampf eine
geschäftsidee gemacht im februar hat er
in einer einkaufsmeile einen trump shop
eröffnet der bestseller ist ein tramp
teddybär wie ein schwamm gewählt wird
werden wir noch weitere vier jahre seien
die fans sind begeistert und werden
weiter trump artikel kaufen
wie viele republikaner hält der
geschäftsmann nichts von briefwahl
er will persönlich seine stimme abgeben
in bucks county stehen die bürger am
wahltag oft schlange um ihre stimmen
abzugeben das misstrauen dass donald
trump an der zuverlässigkeit von
briefwahl gesät hat geht auch hier in
den vororten auf christine zeigt ihrer
deutschen freundin aufnahmen vom wahltag
mit ihrer gruppe hat sie von morgens um
sechs an bereitgestanden um wähler bei
fragen zu unterstützen
[Musik]
mike domenico verfolgt die entwicklung
in der nacht das pennsylvania auf einmal
zu einem der heftig umkämpften staaten
geworden ist in dem trump führt freut
ihn
ich liebe zwar einfach das was er für
unser land tun
ich will dass das weitergeht christine
ständern dagegen bereitet die
dramatische entwicklung in pennsylvania
große sorge wir sind sicherlich
angespannt wir werden jetzt ganz genau
verfolgen die die wahl hier weitergeht
wie die auszählung weitergeht was vor
allem auf gerichts level passieren wird
und wie gesagt ich glaube dass diese
wahl vor gericht vor dem supreme court
entschieden wird die stimmen aus den
vorstädten in pennsylvania könnten in
dieser wahl noch eine entscheidende
rolle spielen
phoenix arizona am morgen nach der wahl
silvia may jagger eröffnet ihr
mexikanisches restaurant die wahlnacht
steckt ihr noch in den knochen
dass das traditionelle republikanische
arizona laut prognose an die demokraten
gehen könnte will sie nicht glauben ich
kann nicht glauben dass das hier ein
lauer start sein soll ich weigere mich
das zu glauben dass draußen auch nicht
es gibt so viele leute die für trump
gestimmt haben alles was er für unser
land tut
silvia ist in der latino community
arizona es eher die ausnahme als die
regel
während zwei von drei menschen mit
islamischem hintergrund joe biden
unterstützt haben ist sie glühende trump
anhängerin den präsidenten hat sie sogar
schon bekocht und ihn umarmt er steht
für ihren geschäften und er steht für
kapitalismus ein unternehmer tour nach
vorn zu kommen
er will unser land wieder groß machen
und das hat er getan und wird es auch
wieder tun diesen staat arizona waren
die stimmen der latinos bei dieser wahl
so begehrt wie nie einen hispanischen
hintergrund hat hier inzwischen jeder
dritte
donald trump der mexikanischen
vergewaltiger nannte hat sie im
wahlkampf sogar mit einem eigenen song
umgarnt
[Musik]
weniger ausgelassen ist die stimmung
während der wahlnacht bei der wahlparty
der republikaner ernüchterung
zum ersten mal seit jahrzehnten könnte
er so nah an die demokraten gehen wie
für die meisten republikaner zählen auch
für die latinos vor allem themen wie
wirtschaft und religion nicht die größte
sache für uns ist der lebensschutz wir
können nicht glauben die extrem die
demokraten da sind keine grenzen für
abtreibung ich meine das ist echt
erschütternd
wir treffen silvia noch einmal beim
einkaufen für ihr restaurant sollte es
einen präsidenten beiden geben blickt
sie düster in die zukunft
das land wird leiden unter dieser
administration
die konservativen werden leiden
religiöse gruppen werden leiden es ist
einfach nicht richtig
sie werden viel regulierung gegen diese
gruppen verhängen und das ist das
problem die latino community in den usa
wird in den nächsten jahren weiter
wachsen
eines gilt für sie genauso wie für den
rest des landes die tiefe spaltung
gehen bei familie menus in florida die
kids müssen in die schule
und trotzdem ist das kein normaler
morgen es ist der tag nach der wahlnacht
und vater bill ist zufrieden
so wie wir erwartet hatten wir wissen
zwar noch nicht ganz genau aber es sieht
gut aus ich bin ziemlich glücklich wie
es läuft will ist geschäftsführer einer
kredit firma hat 38 angestellte wegen
der wirtschaftspolitik hat der tramp
gewählt größtmögliche
gestaltungsfreiheit das wünscht er sich
von politikern
sie könnte nie so weiterzumachen wie
bisher mit seiner handels und
wirtschaftspolitik ganz sicher und an co
wird biden hat ja ganz klar gesagt dass
er das land dicht machen würde
das denke ich es nicht gut für unser
land am strand von clearwater sehen das
viele anders sie hatten auf einen klaren
beiden sieg gehofft sind enttäuschten
welche richtung sich irland entwickelt
ich bin besorgt weil wir 1 land
zugeteilt sind
ich bin besorgt weil die wahl so
unglaublich knapp ist ich finde das
unfassbar aber es passiert und ich bin
sehr besorgt was die nächsten monate
bringen werden
ich glaube das bringt uns in ganz große
schwierigkeiten
ich denke das ist etwas das wir noch nie
zuvor gesehen haben als wir bild zum
ersten mal treffen hat er die ganze
familie mitgebracht trommeln für trump
die kinder sagt er uns sollen stolz auf
ihren präsidenten sein
wie haben sie mitgebracht damit sie
sehen wie viele leute trump unterstützen
und wie großartig er ist die
medienberichten nicht wie viele zahl
unterstützen den medien hört man aber
das hier ist die realität
[Musik]
in florida hat trump auch deshalb
gewonnen weil er besser mobilisieren
konnte und er hat wählergruppen
erschlossen die früher treu demokratisch
gewählt haben
warum sind sie für trump als latina weil
trump einfach alles gehalten hat was er
uns 2016 versprochen hat und wenn wir
ihn gewinnen lassen wenn ihr stimmt dann
verspreche ich haben wir vier weitere
jahre erfolg in diesem land darum flagge
zeigen entschlossenheit demonstrieren so
setzt sich der tromp konvoi dann in
bewegung
ein paar tage später an einem sehr
ruhigen morgen in florida packte seine
traum fahne wieder weg sie so viele
leute seien wütend wir wollen niemanden
provozieren dass sein präsident in der
nacht sich schon mal zum sieger dieser
wahl erklärt hat habe damit nichts zu
tun
na ja weißt du es gibt eine menge dinge
bei trame die ich nicht für sehr
intelligent hat aber aus meiner business
perspektive macht er einen fantastischen
job aber manchmal redet er ziemlich
dummes zeug sieht darin keine gefahr
donald trump sein präsident hat in
florida gewonnen viel deutlicher als
alle erwartet hatten